Speaker 1: Fox News host Mark Levin has been
doing a series of Sunday night interviews
with the failed former president Donald Trump.
But last night's was so absurd that Levin
couldn't possibly save Trump.
When Trump raises a conspiracy theory so insane
that it obviously doesn't make any sense based
on the facts, but it is such a verbal inkblot
that you couldn't possibly clean it up.
The topic was the pandemic and Chinese tariffs.
And Trump's claim is that China made and released
COVID as punishment to Trump and the United
States of America because Trump charged China
so much money in tariffs, which ignores the
fact that Trump still doesn't understand how
tariffs work.
Listen to this.
This is Mark Levine.
Can't possibly do anything with this to save
Trump.
Speaker 3: China.
I was very from I was probably the first one.
I said he came from the lab in Wuhan.
I knew that for one thing, you saw body bags
all over the place, around that lab.
You know, there were body bags all over that
area and nobody talks about it.
But Levin.
Speaker 1: Is trying to stay as still as possible
to maybe blend into the background and not
even be visible.
Speaker 3: In Wuhan.
You had through satellite pictures and other
things.
You had pictures.
Body bags all over the place.
And you can see little lines, you know, from
way up, but they couldn't be anything else.
But I said and I've said right from the beginning,
it was the lab and all they got out, it got
out of the lab.
I think it was incompetence.
I really believe it was incompetence.
More.
You know, people said I was charging China
so much money and tariffs and taxes and a
lot of people said they did it to get me out.
But we did great in that election.
We did.
Speaker 1: I understand what Trump is saying.
Okay.
Think about how bonkers this is, the tariffs
that he was charging China.
Angered them so much that China made and released
COVID, mostly killing people in other countries.
Like, remember, most of the deaths were not
in the United States.
In order to get Trump back now, there's a
couple little problems with this.
One is that that's not how tariffs work.
Trump still doesn't get that when you put
tariffs on Chinese products imported to the
United States.
American companies pay the tariffs.
You are charging American companies more.
You're not charging China.
So it makes no sense on principle.
But of course, of the 6.8 million official
COVID deaths only and I say only like it's
not a lot.
It's an insane number.
But the point is, proportionately, of the
6.8 million COVID deaths, only 1.1 million
were in the United States.
So China, to get Trump back for tariffs that
they didn't actually pay, did something to
kill 5.7 million people in other countries,
including their own, in order to kill some
people in the U.S., many after Trump left
office as punishment for Trump's tariffs,
which they didn't pay.
This is so stunning, stunningly stupid that
even Mark Levin says nothing and is just motionless
like a statue.
Trump then brings up Abraham Lincoln and says
that he has actually been treated worse than
Abraham Lincoln.
Remember, Abraham Lincoln was assassinated.
Speaker 3: Saying that Andrew Jackson was
the most vilified president.
It was his wife died during this thing.
And they said such horrible things.
And he had a very tough presidency.
He was a very good president.
He was a great general and a good president.
Abraham Lincoln, they say, was, you know,
he had a civil war going.
Speaker 1: They say it all right.
Speaker 3: But Abraham Lincoln had was just
vilified.
He was.
But now they say Trump got treated the worst
of all, really?
Because what they did is they came up with
phony stuff Russia, Russia, Russia.
It was all hoaxes, the Mueller witch hunt,
which turned out to be no collusion.
You know, after two and a half years, no collusion.
I couldn't tell them that the first day and
they had the laptop.
They could have figured that out because of
the laptop.
If you look at it, you could have figured
that out easy.
But there's never been anything despite that.
Speaker 1: Is this the most demented, malignant
narcissist public figure of all time?
They say that Trump was treated worse than
Lincoln.
Lincoln was shot in the head and killed.
Trump was investigated for pretty obvious
wrongdoing.
And then Trump claims that he sent former
German Chancellor Angela merkel a white flag
of surrender to symbolize Germany, I guess,
surrendering to Russia.
Speaker 3: I didn't allow Germany to get away
with what they were doing.
I sent Angela merkel a white flag of surrender
because they said when you made the deal with
Bolton, you're getting 68% of your energy
from somebody that you've had numerous wars
with world wars.
I said, So I'm going to give you the white
flag this way.
You don't have to look it up when you surrender
to Russia someday.
Speaker 1: Yeah, it'd be like the U.S. doing
business with Germany.
Even though in the past we were on opposing
sides of a war.
Oh, wait a second.
We do that all the time.
What kind of an argument is that?
Speaker 3: And if you remember, I made a speech
at the United Nations and the Russian delegates.
Speaker 1: That's when everybody laughed.
Speaker 3: And thought it was extremely funny
when I mentioned that they shouldn't be doing
it.
A year later, most of those guys were fired.
Speaker 1: It was actually the entire room
that was laughing at Trump because that speech
was so ridiculous.
Lastly, Trump takes credit for the Olympics
in South Korea being a sellout.
Speaker 3: It started off rough.
Remember that I was saying Little Rock, Ark.
And you're not going to get out?
And I was saying Little Rocket Man.
And he was saying, I've got a red button on
my desk and I'm willing to use it.
And I say, I have a red button, too.
And mine's bigger and mine works and all sorts
of things.
It was very nasty.
And then all of a sudden we get a phone call
they want to meet.
And then I made the Olympic success.
Remember, in South Korea, we're having the
Olympics in nine months and nobody was buying
a ticket because they didn't want to be have
missiles shot at them during the Olympic opening
ceremonies.
Speaker 1: Under to understand what Trump
is saying, he's saying the South Korean Olympics
would have been a failure had he not met with
North Korean dictator Kim Jong un because
people would have been scared of missile attacks
during the Olympics in South Korea.
But thanks to Trump meeting with Kim Jong
un where nothing was accomplished, by the
way, that made the South Korean Olympics popular.
This is a good time to mention I mentioned
it.
It mentioned it earlier in the show.
Bradley Hope has a new book called The Rebel
in the Kingdom.
It's not about Trump.
It's actually about an activist related to
North Korea.
Fascinating book, extremely well researched.
But because of the timing of when the book
takes place, there is a lot in the book that
explains Trump's total failure when it comes
to North Korea.
I will admit I learned in the book that some
of Trump's instincts from the deal making
business world theoretically could have actually
been effective with Kim Jong un.
They weren't because Trump's execution was
a disaster, and it really built up a more
nuanced understanding for me of Trump dealing
with North Korea.
But if you really want to understand, again,
the book is not mostly about it, but the story
will give you an understanding of Trump's
failures with North Korea and Kim Jong un.
Get the book The Rebel in the Kingdom by Bradley
Hope.
I just finished reading it yesterday